Phil Kareem Derek and jeie you meant a
whole lot to Kobe we appreciate you for
being here and sharing your memories of
my husband with us
today as I see today's current
generation of star players following
Kobe's footsteps with huge scoring games
I know he would take pride in knowing
that he is still pouring inspiration
into the game that was so special to
him I don't want to reveal too much
about the Statue before you see it so
I'll leave you with one of my husband's
amazing
quotes leave the game better than you
found it and when it comes time for you
to leave leave a legend and that he
[Music]
did
ladies and gentlemen on your feet to
honor the Mamba Kobe Bryan the new
[Applause]
Statue
[Music]
we want to thank you all for your
attendance today I know it's a day you
all always remember uh and always keep
Kobe in your hearts go
Lakers I want to all of you come to